hey what's up everybody welcome back to
first attack here in Puerto Rico say
champ Romanova dragon ball pools than if
you're following along on smash ug we
have now entered the B section b the red
B you said you have a bone to pick with
the red beam I got a problem because
every time I watch these European events
there's like Tyron and Damascus and
they're talking about the beam like back
eel you know they got like the red bean
yeah
Kid Buu with the red bean yeah we got we
got Lord the night Lord but night with
the B word board the night board by okay
so I got a question is that that be the
red be like a really old man I I don't
know how old it is I just know that we
went white like Evo this year we went
wild with it like it was the evil of the
B it was Bebo vivo what what I
understand I feel like it's an old meme
and I have a theory of that Europe you
know like they still listen to like
techno and stuff I have a feeling that
they get everything 10 10 years too late
and like the B was like a really good
meme ten years ago and these Europeans
just got it just made its way into their
front door now they're like oh don't be
the the big who's gone to the leg loop
I'm here for 10 seconds and I've already
seen teen gohan Auto combo go the
complete wrong direction for no apparent
get used to it because we're gonna be
seeing a lot of teen gohan today yeah
great character and you know LK the
flank of Allah there was just the reek
went recent NL BC where he played a lot
of teen gohan when he was playing up
against Akio switch back to the trunk
steam briefly but if we're playing this
team quite a bit
I love the trumpet I wouldn't do it
great back to front stage but he's never
well he's played a little bit like you
played it this weekend WC is like
briefly and you can tell that it's like
an old flame right where he's familiar
with it but you know it's just whether
you want to stick it out all that blue
life gone blue with a regular B not a
red beam here we go yeah staggers into
the 2m reflect Auto combo again and we
see already some reflect Bates from
alkane he hasn't gone back to it I like
I'll take how to keep in his patience
here does super - in there get hit by DT
Goku yeah the dragon class this age
version is really really good and the
combo off the Venus's that is this
straight by the way it's a lot like bass
go Lewis's and it just like knocks you
off the wall you just go flying yeah
before you swapped in here we had a
match where there was a Gogeta and
abates those one same teams there's a
lot of like dung there like home good
get both of ours
not quite enough
not enough one more set up one more hit
just try and open them up here that's a
kill with NC go Lord Lord I left this
character a long time and so he's not
gonna be able get any of that blue light
back but Zeus Dimas is pre beat up GG I
see zu over from France we think
question part yeah you got to be a lot
bigger when you're throwing out those
six FS of the great mothers on the super
- by the way sniped it with that jump
owl GG go to spawn GC go to action
reflect on the overhead but that should
have been the kill side switch oh no
no it's bright we're bringing it vegeto
yes but the level one to get the
knockdown
and that was a huge drop of help a nice
diagonal feed there from okay this is
gonna take out machito bringing us back
to GG Goku yeah to get to and both spark
install on deck it's a rat attack right
now the rat attack yeah it's a rat be
right the Rat Pack the Rat Pack yes that
was good
oh that was a good block to you
solid deep that's actually so far
assist is down go to beat back up four
Lords I'm not gonna really neat that the
hit gets the head with GG Goku yeah Otto
come on the other side so it's an easy
so it's solo good Gina left rough spot
to be yeah he like walked right into the
auto phone I was like oh no combo spirit
ball yeah we're gonna see it first the
sexier first get you down on stream we
got to see the molars inside this mouth
that was a really good sparking bank
commands row spent that meter right away
that was such a good idea the power pull
defeat the Sparky he just vanished
canceled it too early right now I still
feel like I'm gonna have to wait that is
going to be some heavy damage here but
not enough killed something without
sparking still above that jab yeah this
will be the kill even with sparking you
know every gives you a lot of life but
not enough to either is something like
this right you know a ton of damage
being put out from head there with the
2m man okay that's like two or three big
drop like character killing drops that
we've seen from him in this first game I
mean he gets the job done despite it but
definitely some stuff that you can tie
up some loose ends that he can tie up
and try to
a bit the bit out five hates the rough
blankets the two ends man super - couple
are thinking occurs the PP wins gets the
auto company the other side bottle combo
legs mix up after catches the law that
goes for that load very smart move there
chain minute yeah Paul just a 2l into
the H it is a super - into the snap snap
butter against the day boys so good you
know it depends on which side of the
supernatural on that day whether you
love or hate it you wake up on the wrong
side super nice reversal level 3 we
seems like 2/3 of these so far came in
last time with VP this time with a level
3 you don't want to deal with just like
the snap into the mix up and a pressure
all day right now the wake up DP
autocorrected gets the auto photo they
did a great job on these animations I'm
excited that we're seeing our second
Okita of the day honestly guys will
character while he fell back to the
front after he sandwich them of the beam
extension here with dragon rush that's
the kill wait a minute level 3 no I
thought
okay come on buddy what are you doing
that's like so many drops already with
this team that's like you know yet his
copper picks up shrunken stuff but like
so far I feel like this team he has all
the right ideas but the execution is
just a little off Otto Koppel connects
I miss I kind of thought alive I pitched
like days like your one Lord thank you
oh yeah I mean that's something we
probably will never see especially with
how he's really like to go on right now
okay that one yeah that's like that's
all we needed to see to get the kill
before it ended up working out anyway
and LK gets to keep team Gong alive but
that was how was the rough Rock the
third
okay good job kind of backing off here
or not he blasts there yeah missus this
is getting hints - he comes back away
from it didn't want to get both
characters it all out on the air - back
super - so that's why he is that so you
just get the snap but alright that's
gonna close it out therefore go cheetahs
life
ya know sparking laugh only one Fugit
monster remains yeah this is gonna be
pretty tough I mean with no assists
nothing to lock them down mix-up here
the 200 is a little too short to reach
he tried to match off the - Ella
actually to get himself out of that I
like that idea
2l is pretty good than just a boy to
debate a lot of stuff yeah you know has
good pressure he just doesn't really
have a mix at all so this is really hard
for me trying so
we're not have three barns there we go
yeah that's all she wrote so Lord Knight
cleans it up a lot of drops I think
that's one of those that's where LK
moves on with winters but he's thinking
to himself damn I dropped everything I
dropped like so many of those like
little mistakes that could really cost
you especially down the line when you if
he's playing it up against like if
that's wallow you do not want to keep
the play alive you don't even if that's
base Goku or something you're like oh
man I just miss the combo to kill him
and out there yeah well what would have
caught up with like you know whether it
was go hunt DP assist or phase Goku
something would have caught it so yeah
definitely gonna have to tighten that up
before he gets two more of these
opponents on the winners side of the
bracket
yeah it doesn't end up mattering too
much there it all worked out in the end
but those are rough drops especially
like DP in the level 1 level want to get
the kill that should be like alright you
hit everything else in the combo this is
like the easy part
DP at level 3 I was like oh boy yeah
brother certain characters it'll like
autocorrect the like if they're a little
bit higher than you'll still get the hit
but yeah keep going on isn't one of
those ones yeah it's just unfortunate
too because it's like you have the
difference between like a 2 meter kill
on a 3 meter kill actually wasn't even a
three minute kill the 3 meter nothing
just like three mirrors or eight just
blocks it and then you're like and then
you have to wait for that refresh that's
like the recharge yeah and you spent all
your meter and it's like I could've
killed him I shouldn't kill but it
happens yeah he did alakay is out here's
a lot of players obviously traveling out
to this event who need points right this
is what the last tank ihe event on the
tour so he'll meet you events after this
before the finals are saga events the
saga events in Japan Japan I know that
one in Spain Spain is the other one
right yeah I know so the only thing I
know for sure is that Spain and France
are the two European locations and I
always forget whether it which is which
for the saga and the finals but yeah the
friends isn't final this is in France
right should be good Spain saga should
be a lot of fun obviously the European
events the crowds are always really
create the players out in Europe are
fantastic it's like a nice point for the
players from the US and
head out to Europe as well so i always
love watching the european dragon ball
events they're really really
entertaining to watch
Tyron and damascus meme ended up on
commentary there they're usually who I
usually like embroidery to yeah that's
what I love whether it whether it's us
that our commentators having camaraderie
towards each other or the different
regions having the camaraderie and no
great dude yeah you know like the mask
is working on the tier lists he's
already already planning the new tier
list he's working on at home base form
wah-wah
you know versus goes you know on the
tier list yeah that's true that's that's
one that I'm looking forward to I wonder
- sonic Fox not coming to this event
that's true sonic Fox may lower himself
on the tier list yeah I guess in points
Sonic's at third right now I think right
34th and I think wall I was like right
after I want to say UFA they're hot like
yeah hops here performs yeah perform I
asked here yeah and then I saw the sonic
Fox black when they wore the black
lipstick mm-hmm in Europe how does you
know apart I gotta like I gotta ask how
does Damascus come up with this like is
pirated Damascus on commentariat
Damascus is writing this down like his
brain just goes on hyperdrive like he
becomes he went into the hyperbolic time
chamber Mascis come up to this you know
that's fair so here we go we're getting
into our next match here we have dbx
from Puerto Rico versus Bahnson
from porto rico yeah yeah here we are
and you know the one thing i've noticed
is that there is a ton of people of
whose venue already like it is filled up
super quick there's a lot of people here
early trying to play games and casuals
and stuff and even though i'm like the
mainstay from i was like watching on to
games everything there's a top players
then like everybody was from Porto Rico
there's so many players out here for
their scene and all of them I was like
talking to them about like you know what
do you guys play what do you guys
interested in and everybody was like oh
yeah you don't we have our local left
you see here with bottom right here like
you know they're really excited and
obviously they have a lot pride in their
scene so it's really cool to talk to
them and just see like what the Porto
pretty go have to see it off yeah there
there's definitely a really strong scene
here I've seen so many people with the
PR tag so far today
coming up it's just beautiful in this
place is beautiful too yeah shoutouts to
the hospitality already I feel like they
show people that are coming here to
visit it's a favourite yeah and I mean
this venue is very pretty the hater
blockers the shades and doors yeah do
they go from sunglasses the hater
blockers when you're inside is that how
well you're on stream oh it's all
morning on stream okay he's blocking out
you heard that chatter you can't you
can't affect the one they say is there
all he took off the shades taps and now
yeah no you can just you can be going
you'd be like I bet you'd look better if
you shaved your head completely I feel
bad for laughing that hard but that's
pretty good you know you know I asked
vicious and he said because he's balding
he said if you played this game he
played three ball carriers we're letting
the intro rock here we begin using force
if this is an intro you let rock you let
begin music I cannot believe he's
actually playing free ball characters
that's so time
you got to represent and represent the
BGC my bass is how it is balding gamer
community elder father and flowers
that's the BBC right they're
representing
yeah early super - bus go Chris's is a
really common round start to be honest
we see it so much about 6s yeah
okay yeah rakubian is very very good and
it's one of those assists that you can
always rely on to get extensively from
really far away
unlike most Bemis is it's got a ton of
hits not
[Music]
all the way to the right here yeah knock
down an extension with the Dragon rust
there but design them up to the sky
every sector and that'll do it spends
the bar on the vanish instead of the
level one
same difference Wow round start age hits
boat but only 21 after the beginning a
party key book character sandwiched in
this skate when you usually get ahead
[Music]
yeah try to light light and it did quite
[Music]
high but didn't get punished Cybermen
out six
and the 2h yeah yeah this is the
interesting team too because I mean the
thing about that but if you are going to
play this character you need an assist
that let's have lockdown and setup the
Cybermen and kibbutz this is great for
that right like I mean if you want to
lock down assists you can't go wrong get
ruined oh yeah could've been the killer
actually off the page mystic ball but
I'll do it anyway yeah this is snap
there that's gonna hurt he is dead after
21 pay for that big snap so loco - it's
really messed up right because for some
reason Goku's better when all his
friends are dead I it sounds like a real
dragon ball story it is that's the
mental part is like Goku is the best
when everybody else is dead right like
you want him alone with nobody else to
help um everybody else got mer that he
watched and he's like alright now it's
time to step in and handles yeah we're
on to Isis we see what you're here with
our hero pink clothes level 3 the mods
and old table gonna drop matter we'll
see if there's a sparking betadine
that's this this should be the kill as
long as the share menu doesn't come up
again I think we're doing fine like
first of all it shouldn't be shoot I
have before he sparks Vinnie spark then
he counter spark for some reason then
the share button came up and they played
through it and I was like I don't know
what's happening anymore like we're like
we're in another time mention of Dragon
Ball I don't understand the BGC you got
a rap about the tight-knit community
he's a major player in the BBC Four
he owns the beat you see Wow Wow messed
up Otto farm or the other side of the
napa como it's too fast it's too fast
man
they're like what it's self-command
throw existence but it is better I feel
like we've seen a record amount of
success already land in the second ball
a little early as the late robably
pretty hard rock the Puerto Rico's sick
them and hits every time okay you might
do the level 2 Melfi cannon but didn't
charges just brought nap in and said
does you got more help it's really good
honestly that's bad but it's like they
buffed it like two or three passes to go
to make it like really far it's a good
luck for sure and that's the kill this
is the same spot we saw last time solo
go through this parking chilling by
themselves expecting the 6th
she's gonna do it yeah I was gonna say
it like a meet block this the mix-up up
the golf balls gonna be 6mm or they're
heavy
but he's been punished for Napa right
now that's set up to keep laughing to
get you out there there - eight oh yeah
you should have the five inch instead of
2h actually to reach in the corner but
you know this is all damage seven meters
man
I don't know what plan was but expecting
a level three but not a drop the combo
Fontan manages to live another day Jack
the changes but gets super - that's
super - what's up in those cursed yeah
that was pretty bright there's the night
three of those already on Trina candy
being a little vlog cloudy to find
somewhere really furious
you can to age the right level three and
that is going to take it here
the BTC eggs nice work moving on a
winter side clean as clean as a whistle
he's got a choice
that's true yeah so I mean you have to
decide I think right oh the haters are
being blocked adobe walk so if you had
anything to say about those drums
I got enough but they're their block now
the voices are bought you can't see
anything
John Cena yeah well well played I can't
say anything rude the glasses are back
on that's good oh hey we got big butt
Jackson coming up next I call potato one
of his matches earlier on another stream
it is a big project I promised that his
name I was like you have to understand
I'm on commentary earlier and I was like
looking at the thing I was like so who's
like some of the players I should watch
out for and someone looked me in the eye
and very sincerely said big butt Jackson
would they like Bigfoot bait like they
didn't do it like that but they're like
big but Jackson you gotta watch out for
him and I was like yeah I mean he's
taking up a lot of you know his he's
taking up a lot of space and like
they're like knowing like he made it out
of the pools and winners on the in the
stream I was watching so I see some
thick combos with grease ease I don't
know to be honest like with the name
like big but Jackson you you better have
it going on you know I'm saying like you
can't just and I think this is big but
Jackson and you know I'm saying I feel
like
the name no no I was talking he walked
by us the other person we have coming up
is snick snick versus a big booty big
butt Jackson now if we had not yell up
there though I just thought of this we
could say it was nixed versus snack
sticks versus snacks but what about
snack versus big butt job that's like
equally as good well I don't want to go
there that's pretty good let's keep it
t14 here today because this game tr8 me
right I think so probably for like mild
bye if anything wow how did you know
that well it's like you work at a game
company it's like imagine yeah I guess
that's fair
you're a professor is that a flu is that
a recorder is that the recorder is he
gonna play and do what is happen here
for like 20 minutes and I feel like
everybody's pulling a prank on me does
he know this all the time
what is happening over here but he loses
okay chatroom am I going crazy i blank
chat I've been playing here for I've
been here for 20 minutes and big but
Jackson is on stage while someone's
playing the recorder and they're dancing
like this is not it's like somebody set
this up the mess with me right like this
is a joke does he play maybe he's
playing the jazz hits team I like how
you're completely not fazed by this like
you like be pulled out of a corner on
stage in the school band I was a band
dork alright I played the clarinet okay
so you played a real like a recorder is
not a real instrument it's real to him
yeah it is you're right you're right
you're right
it didn't just if it's real we saw it it
was practically there yeah it is real
it's not a figment of our
ya know solve it so I was like so like
is it like I was like did snakes play on
the streamer earlier with a reporter and
I missed it or something I'm so confused
oh he's playing the yazz flute yeah yes
he is playing the as flute life is just
so confusing man this is just like you
know said every day every day at the job
here sometimes you know you show up to a
Dragon Ball fighters 10k each event and
big but Jackson is playing up against
NYX who's got a recorder on stage and
they're dancing together that's just
like a normal fighting game sentence I
have to say oh you saw it here folks out
here in Puerto Rico yeah this place is
cool by the way for Rico style oh yeah
right there we go
I think Steve and I can do the buter
dance
would you be called tasty Jam yeah we'd
have to I think there's no other way
it's a man that's like the best way to
mash together I think let's go I want to
see a play this on the record of the
West anything his name is Nicholas Oh
goes the bait there yeah you're super
plus after that so fine Dana but
ill-advised you got to just chill out
it's like plump sex or something crazy
it's going to you to City right now
today we got another man here with this
just make it works you vas work of
snakes piccolo
going to need to know the song time to
rewind time for this yeah but one but
why
oh I like that I like cooling out go on
level up one with the assistive cover up
like this are great to like these are
two good assists if you're you know
playing go on I mean this is like the
same as well we see wha what happens
right essentially if you think about
Gogeta is like base Goku so that's cool
yeah Ernesto Vargas block and the wind
punished that's really high damage
starter but another drop from big bud
Jegs
[Music]
the to a punish but even but here we go
we got a profit starting it again big
but what I don't have it's an input air
what what this but that's our plan
looking for elbow drive pressure but we
call it Gogeta again the drop but the
two eighths the big a box for Bigfoot
Jackson his man is living like a hit but
it didn't end up mattering anyway I
think maybe the tail end of it is very
like the just the part of the super oh
that was a great confirm of the good
yeah the double drop sparks up after the
jet oh wow I bought this the stucco
three bars upper level free but also pop
oh there goes up in the air for the
elbow drop blocks the overhead 3h went
the other way a little weird fastball
that's do I put the uppercut anyway big
words from big but Jackson that big VDP
you have these on five you gotta just go
like bus out
thinking about it carelessly right back
into it no intros no time we're back
into it here super - bottoms up thanks
block actually and we didn't see this
piccolo play at all he made quick work
and it looks like it might be that way
again he has his way here finish it with
a reco yeah it's really it's the
character - and he earns that's the
thing about it it's like he doesn't open
to all the draw
get back to H have a chance here no it
looks like you try to hit a button there
and he's already I'm funny with Italy
spark to say piccolo nothing or car
cancel or like you know something right
to try to get out stagger pressure and
the confirm I think the threat of the
command throw is making snicks a little
words
all right pick a level up and the dragon
Russia after for the snap and the spark
out - we saw the same thing on incoming
spark out stagger off that 300 yes we
got the auto combo going in there for
the pressure we have a plutonic off here
but it's a separate stuff in it
dragon rush snap again pair - show over
for the pressure no it's this just yet
you saw the challenge try and keep
pressuring there but we got a level
three fret Vegeta know a bit great okay
off this yeah galaxy breaker we'll see
what's next
runs up just catches up to well come on
two simple options the best the tagging
works it's a head I don't think anyone
quite mastered the sonic box tech on
that yet where they normally will do the
pickup I like that idea - it's really
good - vegeta or basic general right
like it's really good to setup mix-ups
we see that a lot with like especially a
caduceus get a little bit pump back here
drops the loops yeah down techno bar
council hits
Oh elbow drops pencil
that's so good when your opponent's long
life that is such a useful option
especially because cochlea at the book
life you know any you want to get him in
anyway most people aren't really
expecting I think you just do the elbow
drop like that too sometimes it works
your advantage man the spotlight oh
nothing here I thought he's no sparring
I think I believe it himself there
getting another lover here on go on okay
yeah banishes the guard cancel gonna
fall the beams the elbow again no Peter
yeah gets hit low I imagine thinking at
the elbow drop was gonna come I like to
put use of the elbow when you're so low
in life you know why not just track the
overhead over and over big Jack's but it
can you imagine naming yourself big but
Jackson is named definitely not Jackson
right like he just went with Jackson cuz
it's so good with big but yeah I'm
trying to think of something clever with
that but the only thing comes to mind is
like that Nickelodeon show that I'm sure
if nobody's ever heard of yeah
so how old is this Nickelodeon show you
know the actress keke palmer no there's
a show called True Jackson VP True
Jackson VP on Nickelodeon it'll load
that sounds like a crime document no it
was about a girl that went into the
fashion industry did she have a big butt
I don't know what I'm not gonna comment
on that but big butt Jackson the VP's so
that's the tire but we got the detail
stage up here everyone get those D kill
freak that's ready in the chat from the
kill village village the death village
village I always know it's always in the
stream title and I always just click
without looking I'm not gonna you know I
can say that I do that occasionally and
then I you know there's always people
within the chat that like what game is
this when people are like playing a game
and it's in the stream tied off my come
on it's right cool and we have last lap
here so left laughs he's a m'kay player
originally
recognizing some like injustice and
everything and he plays a lot of
different games he's even playing
Samurai Shodown now his mom is very
supportive
that's awesome amma last laugh always
out here running brackets at the
tournaments yes
yeah she's chanting yes she's a true
hero that is a true hero well this is
also a two qualifier match so if as long
as you know this match goes down as
possible she's going to report it as a
loss for the kill/save graduations so
this popular two qualifiers are falling
the brackets are in bracket be 18 in
case you got scared is gonna hit though
I did get the extension but the reflect
whiff
I'll fall down to l-h superdad for the
extension probably assist thank your dad
that hurts yeah that one hurts laughs
laughs - already down a character yeah
somewhere off-screen this brackets being
torn out yeah mama laughs laughs it's
just not happen over you better eat your
supper and beat the kill sage that was
actually so sick from seed did the top
to do the other side for a cross up and
then gods can go on and says but you're
there as well three bars built not span
super - for the mix-up which regime can
go through again apart with us
presenting go good not that much
pressure was really great there from the
till stage so I don't blame laughs
laughter sparking air to get out of that
situation
oh okay gets away from reporter there
yeah the reflec doesn't let the armored
ribs just yeah I'm gonna get calm off
this always keep life is so good
I think the septum about what is such a
big big boy like you know old calls it
through go through the level three here
yeah be here - h6f block the harbor
after beat the tag came in like a
choo-choo train man 20 duck all these
weird because like he's such a big body
yeah the armor obviously but you don't
think about it as like this kind of
character but he's like a really good
stoner actually right which is so
strange place the Frieza I feel like
freeze necklace probably number one zone
character if we're gonna go there
wait Crawley is probably number two
rolling zoning is so good yeah I mean
like that's the thing that's so like
funny about this character right it's
like he's just hurt well Robin he's
really good at this version of the game
he only touches you what he has - yeah
that's true but arms that big it's
actually part not easy to close them up
boy
sparking will build autonomy are here to
get the kill
to the one live for three comfy comfy
okay
father song desc village takes game 1
pretty good you can't go wrong three
characters alive spark up to get the job
done off of the hit saves looks great
and safe well explained teen gohan so it
only makes sense that he were to end
[Music]
good level three the light on or the
auto combo is the legs after you see
that auto combo and then the weight
after it's a see if you'll reflect the
legs and then if you reflect the legs
obviously you can punish that like to em
and do a big combo right after that
lariat drop onto the brawling is this
all the way to the want to tag out there
it's like wits and then Auto Kampala to
the other side to the to have afterwards
great defense there from the base didn't
settle out of that situation but he's
right back in it who's scared reflect
actually there yeah that time stagnancy
st. reflecting it doesn't go for it that
was almost a great confirm off the
falling jump down yeah yeah that was
definitely scary a lot of universe a
doesn't spend anything yeah jump out and
use the Gowanus is for coverage after
yeah it's a really high damage a starter
and a lot of meter for stage it's the
combo though
I feel like I've seen him in extreme
practice that call go like a million
times
yeah well sparks up for level one and it
gets it after
great extensions here at the coast age
yeah 17 hours to so one more three go up
with the downward right into the level
three here bring it down
that is a dead character yeah taking
them out and birth through the Restless
barking to some level it's parkings gone
and you know I've saved get the head hit
this spark off right and be stuck in a
bad spot goes low that time of the
reflect catches it
cranky buster Wow his standing help beat
the legs spots though yeah stupid asses
already used
- that's great Sparkie constants mystic
try to get the extension we saw saved at
that earlier prolene - the jump rag huh
H legs - then he's gone with the level
three in the middle of it straight here
we go
goes right into this this could be a
dead teen gone if he does drop this yeah
it should be easy kill its story it all
worked out yeah use an extra bar but he
got it saves it they will look at each
other and they just aren't laughing like
okay well it all worked out
they're all in good fun here actually
- yeah it's about as far as you think it
should be and then a little further than
that here's a little like except no
stick sticking out of his shoe
definitely yeah it's like actually just
he's got the boot time and there's like
a little knife at the edge of it it's
like it's so good we've laughs man yeah
this is looking great for saved here
aired after the setup should that say
it's all 32
[Music]
I like that it's wearing
old echo fox he got I think well but it
was from last class ever yeah those are
lunch they came out with their kind of
like the vaporwave yeah kind of like I
guess vaporwave is what I would call it
too right I don't know what else
hail way vaporwave paper winds yeah you
did a big walk it's like he's like a
half of the man of his former self
he'll say he's like killing it out there
with yeah you know the nutrition game
and everything but wait yeah yeah I feel
like I seen it he just looked jolly or
in general is like happier you know yeah
he smiles a lot a lot more I remember
one time at Summit I was like talking to
him and I was like you know sage I've
never seen you smile and he was like my
face was just stuff like this like he's
dead that happens like I laugh and then
he laughed and I was like hey there's a
smile like that count
he's like my face is just stuck like
this it doesn't move I was like I see
but these days I feel like he's just
like laughing and he seems like a dollar
fellow I got a meme of him like like
like yeah audience yeah that was good
they use that as a meme a lot what's
good sage I feel like it's a very
memorable person you know like Jesus 20
slots miles or laughs or he gives you
like that like that no sell look it's
really good so yeah that was top legend
C qualifier this is another top any two
qualifiers all the winners sent me into
the pool will be qualifiers in the top
32 which i think is gonna happen later
tonight and the top 16 tomorrow yep as
far as
then I believe top eight is at six it's
either six or eight I honestly don't
know which it's one of the two but you
might be right all right looks like we
got our next batch coming up here on the
stage we got [ __ ] from Puerto Rico
versus lucre from the USA now I am
trying to remember where I've seen Luca
from before and that's a lot of
controllers being distinct right now
yeah people haven't been keeping up with
it you know you gotta think those
controllers is that dark II darker
you're a hero
thank you for D sinking all the
controllers on the console you have it
because if you don't do it it's gonna
happen during your match that's just how
it works so it looks like some stuff
happening off stream right now that are
maybe potentially upstream or upstream
upstream without a power yes are we
salmon
I think salmon swim upstream do you
think that sounds tough yeah I think
it's when there was like a whole episode
of like angry beavers about it like
where they were talking about the salmon
spawning I was thinking about the
Futurama episode oh yeah they do have a
few they did they did about it but that
shows like the difference in our
consumption I feel like yours was a much
more like well thought-out example and
mine was like a cartoon yeah it was just
like that angry beaver though it was
like such a big deal like they would be
like spool for tonight
is very close to getting on the winter
side of table 32 there will be
interesting ribs right yeah that's gonna
be a good man
trying to see what our other batches
here are in the photo rack oh yeah smash
GG look up first attack you can find it
on there happening in Puerto Rico you
can type it in or it's something I think
it some of the future tournaments
actually if you look at future
tournaments on Spanish eg and look at
the Dragon Ball brackets there we're on
B right now I assume we got a have C
bracket after this right okay yeah and
we got apology man it looks like he is
getting close to making him out of his
pool as well as Alucard yeah Alucard new
york really excited to have him out here
freeze a player the freeze the players
have taken a hint for their health this
year we've had a couple of them not be
able to show up him and taki Kawa that's
true and i think they're both here today
what is it about playing Frieza that
ruins your like immune system I don't
know man just the stress the stress of
being a Frieza player in 2018 all right
we got partic coming in here tying the
bandana on we're going into it folks
what [ __ ] froze water you know I feel
like kuba is a far dog player because he
does the bandana too and I feel like
that's like the reason he doesn't speak
man shut off the kuba like jolly fellow
who plays on octo so you can't trust
them
that just means anything either so the
car was 16 star tags immediately in to
go to it
why not that's a great neutral here you
got Auto neutral apart on Larry is
pretty good turns out okay
- that was only the one overhead and
stare that down yeah - Goku assist man
that's this is so good
I'd still like you just get locked down
there that duffel or so I think - the
best assisted and he's gonna get put
that low
I already four bars built off of this
machine right now yeah
5:00 p.m. that's the kill people of
where go repo one one three just the
case and that's the kill
so tagged in to go through at the
beginning and then I mean
and put in the corner bad spot below
cleaned up right away 2:16 I'm starting
to see a trend Oh dunks and it gives
another kid off of here for the reset
okay goes for another combo here the
other a flat bar long is this bow and
hit the vent and some kind of surprised
actually that powerful yeah it beats the
pant all right beat the super down yeah
I mean you can't have heart disease
under that little police I hope
good star cancel and first-time receive
Adele on point actually culture he kills
the Delphi you about the show
okay see the short head for don't I like
it's the one it's super where she has
like a bang yeah I thought that was up
to age and a half wait down there
alright the six this man wants to get
the rat out of here mash the van I don't
know about that bandits though because
although vanishing the vanishes license
it's just kind of instinctual he lost
the corner there which I don't know is
its if it's always worth it but ends up
getting the kill on do you to go go
anyway yeah so one character down on
that side so the things are very even
now again yeah especially with double
parking song deck
alright you gotta see some dr. Roos here
following up and going to a super ago
okay vanishes the stage in that corner
positioning great tech lariat rope to
get more advantage here okay another
tech Breyers really doing a good job
sighs confirm off the rocket this into
the banner
yeah Peter committed though use the
vidal assisting out of it 21 it says
yeah I can't really blank not reason the
level 300 having the three bars like
either player we haven't seen the level
three epic yet on either player so there
a lot of amateurs yeah definitely happy
no choose to your meter quickly you
don't even really think about it yeah
I think it wouldn't for the object there
I do like the sparking there I think
that's really good gonna build some
barns like this junk apples off that
this is a far extension I was just gonna
say the head starter big gorilla arm
swing in the Dell don't drop this okay
you got to kill there that's not the
kill it's gonna be tagged spark
maybe you die for
[Music]
yeah sparks up interesting because you
can also just vanish to extent there but
sparks an interesting idea instead so
that you can guarantee the kill in case
that would have been enough Lucar is
holding the advantage parameter but a
sparking Bardock is very scary to deal
with
get some of the heavy there that's a
good see extension off of it three
available
we go bring up hubby's the power of Liz
[Applause]
not enough to kill all the empty low the
best part about that level 3 is the
thumbs up after yeah you know that's
that's how you know that they have the
chemistry yeah that's gross yeah the
double thumbs up they're like we did it
nice work staggered
I got flashbacks for a second see ya 16
jump media plays like yeah and this
character was just everywhere is that's
a popular character for so long we take
trance right like we thought cell
yeah bear bear like oh my oh my son like
a few other people it feels like tag of
course although the only way to be right
there would have been like maybe jumping
out but no records are really talking
yeah I know that we didn't see like a
confirm and anything else though and do
like a snap that's what I was thinking
after like the 6h oh it didn't reach you
tries to L reaction to beat the with
reflect
bull gets caught the sky by GT Goku
water panco now skip run under ran all
the way under and then Auto combo does
across
okay Thomas here we actually only see
one today on three that's from DT Goku
that's crazy right yeah we seek one
other promote go to but I mean one I
think it's the one that's more high
because you see it less like everybody's
you say to be fair I like the regular
spear box you are that did you go to
spear but I call it the wreck of the
Spirit Bomb that's how you know here we
go look look they're talking about it
look at his bowlers these drops it all
the way down gets the kill
that's a perfect Smile the Colgate smile
yeah I guess it might have some kind of
healthy diet yeah brushes the brushes
his teeth three times a day floss oh
yeah you gotta floss don't get
I pack my floss with me it comes
everywhere oh boy that should have been
a two two aides to challenge the air -
beautiful is on and the killer have
walked here good read yeah you got to be
ready on those challenges on the air -
is over on any sloppy like to H cancels
just trying to open up 16 right now
feeling really bad for Dorothy just
trying to do this
yeah yeah it just feels okay there's the
finally the hit but it wasn't even like
a mix-up it was just you know deep ego
who will assist with me
all right spends a bar to extend the
three-level wider little
in the level 3 okay look at the damage
buck - going into Super Saiyan form it's
so crazy that gg-go gets damaged about
1/1 characters that it's not like at
level threes buff when he's alone it's
like when one character doc commentator
that that they just want to remind us
about GT like yeah forget we're gonna
make sure that we think there's a strong
character did burn it into your brain
yeah a couple of good things about it
a couple of good themes that I like we
could get in the game if we do get a
character is uh maybe Fujita yeah that
would be cool could you man now filly
he'd end up being if GG go goes like
this oh yeah bring it on
solo 21 but give me pet walkers no they
won't do it okay gets the key blast
yeah no-kill going into the box
[Music]
and this is gonna be dad should be the
Oh did not go to the level three there
to close it out yeah that is a big drop
air to end this is the kill
yeah there's no drop here this Nick
killer oh well I thought they're gonna
go into the dive or vanish after that or
anything else that was yeah sure yeah
you need that killer banish the vanish
vanish to vanish so six teens got a lot
of life you need two solid hits three if
you're unlucky so this is the star yeah
give us an extension off the H dive
level three okay turn him into a snack
no this does get pretty good okie to
still offer this level three and you get
some health pack which is nice if I
won't matter the jump me into into the
dragon rush you can try to extend as far
as you can here drop vanish what what
still available try to see if it'll kill
why though try that drop comes all the
way back around and this 21 live for so
long damn that's a lot of water it's
like that's a lot of water
got a clinch here it's still got the tag
on it when there's a man in these pools
named the big big but Jax they cut Jax
and you got a puncher thirds
[Applause]
I'll go to a try it's okay you'll get
used to me say yeah I got daddy mom
jokes today's bout it's just a Romanova
special I didn't realize
it's a 50/50 or either going to get some
analytical talks about to bar kill out a
great star for Luke are just like quick
to open up put them in the corner from
some solid offense standing in for the
kid before the open up here drop the
combo nice lock in the overhead oh the
dragon rush not gonna hit they're both
types the call is a great take a man
okay fine the openings opening up here
in the corner with Android 21 yes I can
it overhead connects
level three get some of that blue light
back I mean 21 was the magic character
last game so I think spending a level
three is probably worth then we'll see
if there's a spark
what's the mix gonna be okay the jump
tail try to do the same thing as last
time essentially did not work this time
on favor Mel's really good few friends
know 2h down Tech tries to hit a button
I actually don't know if nope.avi still
playing under-21 but that is like the
special after the Greeks will always be
like trying block this from the blast
yeah those rocket that's still very good
extension gracia level 3 no gonna go for
another setup pad the hip pull with a
little too late off a - L - M starter
hold the van this is high damaging
because there was no vanish that hit
yeah you talk about that damage look at
those three bar 30 filled and we're
gonna have a dead 16 here from just to
level one
yeah didn't even need the excavator but
I think spent that because 21-3 low so
once they get to do it out of there get
a little bit of that blue health back on
deck
granted the better assist here is
probably the GT go good yeah but you
know he's got so much life you might as
well try it keep him in
Pogo jhump28 hit great defense here from
uber the dragon flash this actually
challenged the beam I always want to
give props people if they can't actually
block it all right like granite like I
just feel like some eight characters
with the records you never know which
way they're gonna go sometimes like with
Android 17 the really hard thing for me
about the vending car is the jump hair
bro like it's so good because your
natural reaction is to stand up and once
on it will clean this character that's
what everybody was getting hit by and I
guess the cops over to you super - sup
[Music]
okay it's not parking there get out of
that it's not having to deal with amber
21 anymore here definitely needs to find
your opening against her oh the jump
back that button is so good one of her
saving grace is for forever act like the
entire games lifespan it's been like
even about 21 is that good they like put
the jump at the jump back is so good
there yeah I guess that's very that tail
is just like a giant baseball bat
beating you over the head
yeah you just waiting with it from
downtown really really good
[Music]
all right so a lot of life for [ __ ]
characters here [ __ ] really making a
comeback again again like you were
saying earlier that you ever 21 is just
a really strong character for for make
these yeah it definitely seems like
that's the money character so far like
the other two it's like all right it's
Bartok Knutson totally right these are
you know but 21 is the care of tonight
like [ __ ] wants to play Brian seems
like anyway I like that reflect ride
upon it
[Music]
and not quite but we got the auto combo
in here all combo after the exam find
you a falling mix-up at the TF 21 that's
a little greedy it wasn't airtight or
anything
Wow eh overhead beat the power pole in
the level three very bold move and I
liked it going right into that level
three not enough to kill mix up here
stopped backed out of it
6m block the challenge you can't beat
the new the jab gap your older self
[Music]
[Applause]
he's bigger he accounts right first
Samantha I think we've seen so far
Autocar laughter I'm gonna agree with
you I didn't eat so as well not so much
this should be the kill five Anna's
extend a little bit of the level dreams
yep she's gonna eat this tasty treat yes
wait she needs to eat this delicious I
believe they did a handshake before was
even over Ottoman might now hold on
let's make sure tonight's work moving on
in winter sign that was the top news you
qualify as we mentioned earlier right so
the qualifiers are happening right now
for a lot of the pools in case you guys
are following along smash GG and then if
you look at feature tournaments you'll
see first tack on there right on the
homepage yeah the front page is smashed
on gg
so it's a good time to take a look at
the brackets and see where we are we're
on qualifiers like for a few pools like
the B pool is what we are in right now
and I see we have another one coming up
with Chris G it looks like over there
but before that we are gonna take a
short break so hopeful you've been
enjoying all the Dragon Ball action will
be back with more right after this
in the end he kept getting checked and
then what makes you so good about that
yawn services but what if this is in
fact it'll make those super dad say yeah
and the one thing about apology man I
like is you can always tell exactly how
he feels it's all over his face he
looked miserable I know I know what went
wrong here there was no microwave in the
hotels we couldn't get
i gotchu yikes they didn't have a a
minute you know that one minute one
minute on the microwave back that sets
president set up up with that 2s and he
wasn't having it just counters out of
there
we're gonna back up lets me set the
neutral I agree or we own them
nice Casanova has been failing here
trying to break these but he's dragging
him rushing but I like our apology man
sticking the man definitely worried
about the boss up but we're talking
about the quarter no yeah any reflect
the last time do guard cancels set up
the Genesis might save them it does Oh
half yeah he couldn't get high enough in
time should a super jump for us I feel
I'll be all getting grounded here Otto
gone climbing piccolo down the chimney
oh he is getting a press assist rings
this is the cello the guitar everything
oh no he got out the corner with the
upset and now he stocked for studio that
makes up bull that's just available what
is it gonna be fastball nice block the
block guard cancel gets chewed up by
that Yamcha says Balaji man in trouble
he's already spent level what's parking
oh okay good blocks but that's all you
can't do so I'm just gonna say just
block regardless nice counter poke okay
yeah we recognize that there was gonna
be a stagger right here's the look I'm
sick of this level three spends it with
piccolo here so that he can get the
Senate with him and see an assist
instead some big damage from behind from
beyond the office from the top of the
game ow that jumping l caught him out of
the air but he didn't have time to get
the combo afterwards mr. own apology man
there that could have been big right
there focaccia Gokul nice break unhand
me says apology man and the edit it
we're gonna take it to the sky we're
gonna spend that cash no we try to set
up that hell zone behind the back you
might get pulled 3 2 1 I wonder if we
actually did one covert action turn
around their heels an apology man kind
of setup but that actually bit up in the
gluteus max and you are going some hold
this family tree kamehameha and that's
gonna be the kill piccolo goes down no
sparking for apology man he's in huge
trouble here say too bad you still got a
social assist nice that's plus all right
don't pop try and keep it still but nice
multiple kossler don't go see that
reflect their then the super - cancers
drops the elbow again and here it is you
just have to block assists on deck
what's the mix-up late air - the pluck
yeah he was looking out on that third
eye but finally get split low
flags absolutely we're trying to air
their no air therefore my apology man
that fadeaway jump medium and that's
gonna do it for TN here definitely was
bailing in Casa no-go came out on top on
that one
and he's powered up oh this is looking
terrible like father like son
but this time it looks like oh don't go
on it's gonna finish the job here solo
go through here reflect what the Yamcha
says always the spoiler for causing
Augustin the star of this team looks
like it's safe to say apology man will
be going through these spectators see
but I'm not gonna count them out yet
that is the poster boy that is gold one
of media Africa from Gaza no go with the
kid bosses just to make it extra spicy
drop that elbow on one more chance y'all
just as misses there it is the fadeaway
jump back key blast the W for Kozma no
Co here is gonna send piece post apology
man home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everyone
we're here at first attack Puerto Rico
Dragonball Fighters 10k each event
I'm Romanova joined by say Jam yeah
we're here at the last 10k each event of
the tour the only two events after this
are saga events and then the finals for
Dragon Ball so this is like the last
race to get points you know there's a
lot of people who are on the tail end
they're trying to get those live wool
spots like can I make it it can I make
it past this spot so there's a lot of
people who are trying to qualify into
the tour you can see the standings over
on the BBFC website just like up DB FC
world tour you'll find the website for
it and this gentleman right here was in
topic like last weekend at UCT yeah but
had to fly back a little early yeah I
had a family emergency so I'd leave
early but you know shout outs to him for
making it that far and I'm sure we'll
see many great things out of Chris G
today playing team go on mm-hmm yeah
he's always been a fan of this character
right even before teen Gohan was like
really really good in the beginning of
the game this is a character he messed
with a lot he spent a lot of characters
like for a while like you know he was
like early adopter of Yamcha like go on
wrong yeah I was always a fan of
Christie's trunks especially because he
chooses the yellow colors and yellow
track yellow dress jacket trunks is just
swagger for days it is cheating yeah
I'll be honest with you actually think
that trunks has some of the best color
options in the game because of the
ability to like match the jacket and
then have like the jacket be offset by
the shirt color like it's like really
good yeah he's definitely swagger for
days and days and days when you come
from the future yeah you can just dress
however you want you're like look 10
years from now trust me these two colors
it's too good we're just long this kind
of like next level that you don't
understand oh the hater blockers are
back on we're bringing this player back
out wsf we saw him play earlier
that's true oh you play steamboatmen
team BGC that's right this looks like
maybe a button check though some Napa
see some Napa again wait
yeah this is this isn't mean I think
this is a button check I think so too
because Android 18s air so that doesn't
count I think this is this private
lecture we'll see I don't know maybe
it's long I think it's a bunch exes I
don't think Christy's playing cooler
yeah also the shades are still on as you
mentioned the hater blockers are locked
and loaded I think those will be
unactivated once the mash starts me
activates but
this game has a good soundtrack yeah
definitely very very solid even though
like waiting screen to like you
that music is so good yeah when I'm like
in a stream and that's just left on the
background like too extreme and I'll be
like okay I can I get go with this
that's good this is great music in this
game good soundtrack a lot of the
character themes were they saw headset
on hater blockers off alright we're
serious now we are going with Frieza the
weight no Christian weight points prison
yeah he's been playing Frieza I look for
an ECT I saw a blank Frieza yeah yeah
Chris Chris cracks me up because like I
feel like when Yamcha was like really
really good he needed plenty option like
before that and after that he's been
playing a lot of Yamcha he's like
switched around a lot so yeah been
playing some Frieza I seem to play some
Frieza
and I as you mentioned I've seen him
play succeed Gohan do you think it's
from him moving to the west coast so
he's become a little bit of a character
hipster alright what are you suggesting
about the west coast what was that there
was like some more importantly I feel
like there was an underlying dig in the
ribs that just got shot to the West
Coast way what was that it'll be okay
yeah I was like what the heck dude was
gonna fire shots at the West Coast no
but you do have a lot of the most
hipster areas out west yeah yeah
to be fair I feel like - I feel like
Chris she has always been a character
hipster right like he never wants to
play the characters that are like
everybody else is playing and stuff he
always wants to do his own thing and
like pick some weird stuff he rides his
own way yeah
it's a good way to live life I go I do
like the freezer though I love I love
what we do get to see a good Frieza it's
always really fun especially when
there's always that chance they might
for some reason go golden golden is
great it's like you yeah gold is
beautiful everything gold
super nice off the GG go through
yong-chul no doesn't open the extension
just close with this that looked like a
bait on a reflector a tag into nothing
from chris has waited it out try to use
the yacht justice Falls of that jumping
out this Campos I gets on there with the
- yeah Chris that's one thing about it
always really really solid combo outside
you like
hair that John Bell and that should do
it even with notes this year
know what GDX was doing there
therefore his defects but does fall out
of the combo though you gotta watch the
tag here for Chris that's what he's
looking for waiting for him to tag in to
Napa or getting you well earlier we're
talking about zoning so here is the
Premier's owner I hope the game if you
want to call characters such Wow whoa
there's an issue yeah there's a
controller issue I think something's
wrong something's wrong with one of the
controller
[Music]
he just wants plaything so does that
mean I think by official rules game one
has to go to Chris G for that I think so
yeah there was an issue with the
controller Oh No yeah unfortunately
unfortunately guys you think by official
rules that that game does automatically
regardless go to Christian yeah cuz I
saw him like walking and he's like
looking down and then Chris G like took
off the headphones and I was like oh no
there must be something going on I
thought for a second there might have
just been a whole bunch of disrespect no
because I was like trying to figure out
what's going on and so I looked at the
player cams and then I saw I was like
okay yeah that's why see we hear we have
the player cams that you the people
don't always see you guys are busy
watching the match so I had to educate
you and be like alright here's what's
happening I got you I'm looking out for
the people at home I'm like you know I
and your eye in the sky that's what it
is it's the eye of the stadium bunch of
hair that I'm looking out for
okay finds the hit there that was a low
I think on the ground actually but he
had quite mated that I was really really
cool yeah I like I'll backing out of the
desk okay it's the heavy I'm surprised
Chris planet pockle app but some pretty
good missed its extension which easy
Goku yeah
spar this could be the kill this is
gonna be great damage here if you off
that extend them with the GG Goku beam
we're gonna see y'all chances goes into
the dragon rush
yeah six meters the span
level one we gonna see spirit bold will
think this I bet we are I think that's
right level three seven meters per crazy
okay
oh look so Chris okay the sex after that
success closing it out that feeling but
your como does nine nine nine nine
damage you just needed one just a little
bit
tell Avenue Paul maybe the one hit that
didn't hit full leaving us guest a car
in the front - H Oh interesting - agent
- the princesses yeah the great defense
there to get back on the offense of EDX
but Chris G still relentless here
okay okay you just reflected yeah like I
reflect and the GT gogo is this for
Chris I'm surprised we haven't seen it
to snipe these air approaches a little
bit
that's a really good option that not be
able to that just hurts and a declares
yeah not having something where you know
you have locked out available to use Rob
prefer because like in to assist okay
this yeah a lot of dampens on this
markings running out for dbx here one
one
of space clean as ever Christine looking
really solid
I guess he just let's play this game out
he forgave him for the last one oh yeah
I guess we'll see after this right dang
he built so much being a [ __ ] bar for
Chris Chris do it the golden he's just
getting it out so show now folks
he definitely is Christie's is that he
figured it out it's like all right I
think I'll be okay
he just super dashes in this man
extension vanish dragon rods level one
Chris G you know sometimes you recognize
that you're like I think I can get away
with a little style man that disc and
then he news gonna up back and just
built four meters I was like you know
that's good I think about the disrespect
because you'll have these people that
are very fold online and do it just in
front of you and you're like what are
you doing what's your problem
good block on the cause of actually
I know he had a teleport Gator on the
dish I love it these combos too that
we're seeing here
another bar that's why to like most
people don't have an ability to get away
with that kind of thing but since they
have to block it coming back they just
Chris can get away with it yeah kind of
super - you get hit by it or something
we saw managed to beat it but then you
lose your meter or so like I've known
that's a spark off the - em starter
we suprise okay what is called o g9 nine
nine nine or ten thousand that's the
question I think this one is actually
going to
unless there's a test scale here
well thank fence at the end I don't know
he didn't go into the spirit ball for
this one yeah that kill this pond 10,000
[Music]
yeah pretty good spotting Krista chillin
obviously dbx have sparking but solo kit
boo is a rough spot to be reflect he
didn't take out of it but that was still
pretty crazy that Chris mean all the way
up there in time Sparky
yeah I mean you could tell Chris he's
kind of on autopilot at this point
- eh we'll dive picked out those nice to
avoid the Dyke thing actually that's
usually not not easy to do when your
staircase is wait sit down
Oh dd-did belfry while
[Music]
yeah there we go to kill Christie takes
it to Oh
DB axe tried to defend the BG Siva Chris
he's got plenty of hair is it tough he's
a tough opponent I've not only him but
the you know I've not known always from
my observations but on that one I'm
pretty proud of it that's pretty good I
think when it comes to hair you know
that sort of it's my realm with
speciality so these have all been ball
fire matches in the top 32 and I think
up next we have another one I know that
there's an apology event set and there's
also an L case that Lord Knight up
against rims I think is one of the
matches that we were probably gonna get
I see that I think is next actually yeah
I think how far has this ballpark match
so I should be getting more free to play
for those of you who are freeze the fans
at home it's good to see okay back up
here still going strong on the winter
side yeah have some drops earlier as I
said that we've bought some play on
streams but still overall I think play
pretty pretty well and lately has been
playing well in general right had that
second place at ect and it just had
second hats and I'll be c2 Nakia he's
been grinding the game a lot I think
playing better and better in the flag is
set up oh it's raw actually yeah
no okay ect actually get dirt you know
cut second coach Steve is that I only
remember because it was like one of the
first times I've seen coach Steve I
think knew that yeah yeah are you yeah I
think you might be right it was a sonic
boss versus coach Steve grant finals
which was like insane to see because
this sounds like a fever tree if I have
you might be right no yeah you might it
was not the expected outcomes are right
check I think you're right yeah it was
not sorry I didn't mean to correct you
it was no I mean you might be right it's
he got second or third right wide beep
I'd be a bad commentator if I didn't
remember matches that i commentated oh
you calm and attitude okay with it yeah
I'll trust your opinion I was not there
I was sitting in bed enjoying a nice
lovely weekend home yeah there's a lot
of like I mean you're probably on to go
all the time because of the stuff you do
yeah this is like my time like every
weekend like from now and like till the
end of November I'm doing something
whether it's an event or like going to
see family for the holidays
oh yeah say no that stuff's coming off
it's like that relentless I always
forget about the holidays that are
coming up a chatroom if you guys are out
there you should say hi to your family
for the holidays call them figure out
plan ahead of time you know what I mean
that stuff is important give them some
love yeah start planning your Christmas
gifts can I can you believe that it's
already time you got to start thinking
it's uh I feel like the first day of
like November it's time Christmas musics
coming out got a hang the ornaments and
I feel like we're gonna be getting some
gifts here soon
from
ARC sis and bandai namco like we saw
them like starting to tease I think
SuperBrawl yeah that's true so it looks
really cool no idea went but really
excited to see that character come out
man that beanie is like the brightest
people planet it is like I feel like
yeah it is like a beacon it's like a
lighthouse what's the area 51 to get
that one that like just looking at this
beanie I feel like the whole world is
staring at it right now I'm a little
upset that he doesn't play like an all
green team like having like piccolo on
his team or something that's true Sal
piccolo
I guess Bartok works he has green in his
outfit yeah I'll take it alright I'll
allow it
all right we got Lord Knight coming up
here you know what it is teen Gohan oh
the dramatic intro oh don't do it to him
don't step on my boy
you gotta hear the birds cry
let it out folks man it's like the music
in this when it happens in the show is
so crazy it's so good that's so exciting
too because you always get to have that
that on then some time to let it rock
yeah the dramatic it feels great Wow
back hands look beautiful that was so
good on the reflects off the trade right
there really really good
a little bit I respect it did not vanish
after that kit for the key black yeah
awareness don't question this game is so
important to know whether you should
back out or whether you should go for a
black but you get a one square foot
strikes again folks
oh those ringing 11:3 this is this is
what I've been calling
especially after ECT velour thank
special as soon as those three parts are
available and he can use them he does
I'm just so upset about that was like
the most Paris part yeah was put the
battle on Auto pommel legs hair - over a
hold the vanish that you don't get lose
a lot of the scaling man I like that
choice a lot that was yeah it's gonna
build up the two meters and that's what
he needs to kill he's got a little team
small hurt box
sparking off the table al-qaeda a huge
lead actually one one character a
wonderful life care to like this is
really really big in this game
yeah chased the backpack
all right technically taking this time
era being a little patient definitely
respecting reps here except that he was
reflecting when he still went in with
that Auto combo virginity toku - it's a
confirm it's just a sin m ki blast - age
lot of beater to dump on those
yeah I mean even after this you got
three bars left so you get another hit
you're gonna have you're not going to be
building meteor penalty but yeah land
too late
super dad for the extension goes low
reflect out and I think that was just
waiting for a super - we're seeing what
he'll do okay played a pretty sane yeah
patience at that situation go right into
the dreck rush here no break build up to
five meters here spent down level three
for the set up
yeah I mean if it kills yeah I like that
reflect a lot that was really good yeah
that man was ready to reflect and it did
work to his advantage here we bring in
GT Goku they know that this assist helps
his team are all the empty loss of the
reverse call marathon bashes Bru seven
meters almost doesn't spend anything
that'll do it dragon rush off the whip
alkanes GZ go go out of there this is
gonna make it a lot easier here for risk
I feel like the combination between teen
gohan and GT focuses is just too strong
right now the better yeah it brings you
back down to the ground it's one of the
best like cutting off diagonal space on
the screen and forcing you down the
ground for mix-ups one three one one
three horse you down to the ground locks
you in is this so good
blows out of the air
yeah easy to combo off actually it's
unlike cell assist which diagonal but
harder to call macaron back that front
wake up beautifully time this is quite
the comeback here for wrist again for
night yeah he got him down to two capers
early right we saw okay spending
sparking to do it but half of that it's
been already so far definitely needs to
get himself out of this situation
okay the jabs gonna do it for him the L
cave match like always comes out
taking those eyebrows off you don't need
makes your face look weird though yes
you have received people without
eyebrows it's it's actually kind of
weird like if you were to shave your
eyebrows and come back on screens yeah
I'd be terrified wanna beat her on that
yeah I had a feeling I mean it's it's
weird like that I think maybe if we did
jump to ages and then there maybe did
I'm not sure but getting that the work
right is a little hard actually
I mean Bartok ended up getting in for it
though which is probably okay
oh he's just trying to go for the level
three think he was gonna hit a button no
fun is that was brutal okay I think
that's a big bet but I don't think you
gotta bet that big if I'm honest this
man out here with the beanie yeah it's
out of control I mean to be honest
Europe in this game is very very very
good at drying ball right and I think I
think to be honest this weekend I
probably expects unless there's some
upset I actually expect that we'll see a
European final so you know in this in
this case like okay as well as you've
been playing I don't know if he's the
favor here the trunk trunk
you just blank trunks ahead help me see
this is like he was down like Nakia was
looking like he was gonna close it out
easy peasy and then the switch the
trunks actually got him a reset in the
bracket so change the future change the
future that's what I mean to be fair you
know why trunks has to change the future
in the game it's cuz I mean that's like
the best thing in this is so good it's
so good and even on point change the
futures possum takes up so much of the
screen beat slaw projectiles you block
it in the air you're stuck for like five
million frames okay she really good
assists right now backing up his bar dog
here so let's see if you can turn this
around change his future yeah and
honestly I think right now I like okay
his bar talk a little bit more than the
teen gohan in general but he went in
with that lariat did cover and was it a
suit there
[Music]
- I am
they're gonna change the future trying
to side swap there
I'm gonna fall down lands and crime
Bardock assists after the rolling cross
larious out of the corner o mates that
yeah I gotta take the snap
all that was
coming another thing I think that change
the future is this does so well and also
is that you just can't see really what's
going on it does kind of like makes
visibility harder yeah structuring
that's like really useful right you just
you just start it's hard to see what's
happening he was like even what trunks
on point it's hard to tell what exactly
happened it's not the the hell's own
grenade effects one of those characters
you can't really back that far to call
them out here
yeah the extension off change the future
as well we'll probably see Bartok go out
here I imagine from LK yeah
that is a bad drop there 4lk very
unfortunate one
and the ones bar lotto combo second hit
starter
all right so sparking out for bolting
them down
[Music]
Oh on the plaque
yeah knockdown jump 2h super - beat the
tag LK is giving up a lot of live here
attacking these characters in and out
and just getting hit all that jumping
hits boy oh boy this is looking like it
could be an upset here for LK yeah Larry
jump combo Leslie easy P to kill energy
bill
a beatdown I think LK esteem kind of got
discombobulated after that spark and
then that tag you know he just got
called out for it
and we lose this I'm never gonna hear
the end of it buy your wife a diamond
you don't play Trump City
I mean his Trump Stephen is you know
this is the comfort pick but like wow
are you serious
kamehameha level three to be fair like
okay won't you sit there so that's like
the second time we've seen this was that
I call it that was I don't know what the
call-out was with the tag maybe you just
want to tack about I'm not sure like
it's not like yours
vinick's Parker
star council change the future in the
air yeah walking in the air is pretty
scary change the future cancel but stop
backs it
I'm not quite seeing a lot of the mixes
that we see a lot of shots Clara shoes
with a spin not getting sword spins yeah
okay haven't really had a chance to do
too much wow it jumps out of it but the
gg-go who assists to keep it safe yeah
yeah full on a meter that just feels
like it was committed and like the
reward for solo you know yeah easy kill
rmz looking very strong right now here
she came against Lord Knight could
easily take the King to setting for
tonight to the loser side
yeah Larry it over and then use the
assist plus frames nice that was
perfectly fine g-tube our buildings the
assist to extent that'll do it
javelin energy field and LK down to that
losers bracket r MZ bacon that game
clean man Europe is so good yeah they
have so many talented players and a lot
of them are out here they've been
traveling quite a bit for this game not
only just to other events across Europe
but all over the world
[Music]
it's weird over here they got a
different ocean than I'm used to
yeah yeah some odds aside yeah the
Pacific is where I hang out so I'm not
quiet you know well the Atlantic is
where it's at that's where this is that
but it's not where it's at
I've never been to a beach in the
Atlantic ode off the Atlantic Ocean that
I thought is nicer than a beach in
California anyways folks thank you so
much for joining us again this is first
attack in Puerto Rico tech ket stop for
the Dragon Ball World Tour the last guy
you chased at last thank God you stopped
yeah we have to saga events left and
there's a little while until the next
one anyway the Japan saga sign ups just
went up and you know it's gonna be it's
gonna be interesting man I just thought
they'd censored me they didn't want to
know about the Hidden Dragon Ball saw
gonn hosting in my backyard
no I'm just kidding it's not happening
so we got apology man up on the stage up
against super Manila 2.0 okay do you
think apology man apologize to the bank
teller that he asked for Puerto Rican
currency - I can say with all of the
belief in my heart he'll know he just
like took his money and left he ran
immediately to his car and like sat
there and tweeted that tweet apology man
you know if you didn't see the tweet he
went to the bank and and handed them an
envelope of money already suspicious
handing them an envelope of money and
said hello can you please give me Puerto
Rican currency for my USD and the bank
teller said okay grab the envelope
and handed it back cuz it what currency
do they think that here's the problem I
have with this right if you're gonna go
to a foreign country and you want to get
money like there's two steps that happen
before you go to the bank the first step
you look at the exchange rate and the
currency right the second step don't you
call the bank to make sure they have the
money you call them like hey I'm going
to Japan you guys have any yen and
they're like no maybe this branch will
have right like it's like very normal
thing to do right yeah usually they
don't exactly so what was the plan gonna
be anyway then he didn't call ahead and
he just showed up and was like let me
get some of the PR bugs y'all got any
Puerto Rican dollars pesos what do you
guys got yeah milk the milk was cold but
let see if the milk is warm right now
for apology man as he goes up here
against super Manila 2.0 this is 2.0
dude it proved new and approved yeah who
know at one point oh that was you know
we're just trying to think that 2.0
though the future an apology means
another one who has been playing Team
Gohan yeah very good character and not
that surprising I think right he he
tends to pick the characters that are
very very strong and like fit his team
well
another another father-son stay here yep
you talk about the glowing easy-peasy
drop snap I think try to bait the VP on
incoming hits the side switch with the
elbow anyway that's why positive isn't
commence anything but the thing is is
that if you're a super vanilla you don't
actually know which character you have
coming in or so maybe it was thinking
about it boss the buzzy bug rate but it
still doesn't matter still man you hear
a hit here and this is just pickle it's
still one of those characters that plays
because that that is so well yeah it's
very very good at it there are some
characters that you're well sup that you
don't see it as much with yeah
this is already like quick work of this
Broly yeah he has notes like formulas
game plan you know it's like it kind of
just like you know exactly what apology
mannequins doing every single game and
if everything goes right it's gonna look
the same every time
that's why I don't like blank Niccolo
players that are locals because I know I
know if I get hit I'm just making it
snapped but that was a great bait there
yeah the counter was really well played
you see a lot of I feel like these days
hit has been more and more common and
he's a solid character to be honest like
he really controlled the ground well and
he's one of the best counter punchers in
the game I think particularly the
counter in the air to do super - people
don't like him anymore you're probably
gonna get hit by something that you
didn't expect you're supposed to get hit
by like that right there's gauge stand
it's the snap bring in Goku miss honey
coming
yeah challenge try to go with the
command ass to the other side of Hardman
was ready for it character for you to
try to get rid of hot apology man
because this is a character he's been
playing since the beginning he was like
no a lot first Goku at the beginning
right yeah and I think also I mean it's
just good to cut off like you know it's
a big part of the team I think we tried
to space that out to beat the sparking
honestly just a little too close I agree
he also like for a while instead of beat
no piratical is like he was called the
nail yeah
that one was although these days you
know he's traveling a lot take a look
very good no he's solid he's a different
style than like so craniums gonna
piccolo player kind of beautiful Damian
sees these players have all these
different styles we're going to a hit
for the free to em oh just get by the
air now
yeah - all in the extension hair level
one table doesn't bring him back down
the ground man Andy get the tag team in
was escape those legs - which was good
for him
yeah you know so far him feels like a
Pollock even maybe not that comfortable
dealing with hit on the ground at all
the air to air jumping hell after the
hit but unfortunately drops the rest of
the convoy to be honest he looked really
uncomfortable against this character I
think he's got to kill him soon uppercut
level 1 to try to get as much as he can
no no quiet not there it is the piccolo
this is gonna close it out I think we're
gonna see a different change of pace
here now that that character is off the
screen yeah I mean it's a solo cooler
now I hear apology man you can slow it
down a little bit sparking still a male
mr. Campos Oh actually committed to the
legs yeah I feel like spoons not as
scary you are as warmed up repeat he's
of the fainted level 3 yes 3 bars on
that
yeah stupid ass with a combo half there
piccolo a sense though with the auto
Connery seconds gets clip I think a
college event this time like looking at
game two I think the plan is when you
get a hit early you need to snap and
preferably next time kill hit like the
less that character can play the better
it is probably for his positioning to
snap which it looks like he's about to
get hit in his first form is anything
here with piccolo yeah knock down sides
which with the elbow bring admit I think
that sparks out early spark take and I
think if you're a baggage and that
you're okay with that
do you think he was maybe gonna try and
go for the fuzzies in school it's a big
body like that yeah I mean you good
buzzy I mean this is a big team that's
the problem with this team in general
right he has a go Christmas here
man yeah bro ACS how it goes world is
hot nice blog
it's the managed to keep the corner
positioning Wow gets that low hit there
yeah this is big man about school let's
fit bar to here yeah just take the kill
but one one one more to do it
good news at least you know hits coming
in again same position no sparking man
working out perfect that looks like I
think he's been shipped out at all but
there's the hit hit that age stands
crossed back up into the front you tried
to warn it you tried to warn apart the
might with it he needs to take care of
this character early and it's already
proven to be a little bit threatening
but not threatening not to piccolo here
yeah three jump off Oh
oh yeah for the super - then dragon rush
Fuzzy's block the can but he gets his MO
same exact thing as last time block the
hole buzzing just the two hour after hit
snap and no more sparking to get you out
of this situation gonna be hard to see
what's going on here
Rob this is like you know if you're
super vanilla the amount of time you've
actually chosen to do stuff it's like so
low at this man's gonna hit over and
over level one level three especially if
your spot or your sparking is gone like
yeah that's your one chance breakup
Spence barking if I don't immediately
kill piccolo or like reverse this
positioning I'm gonna end up in the
exact same spot do this though this is
looking grim for him
yeah College eventless barking - sighing
it's gonna be sparking
Oh with the key blasts can accept this
to kill though gonna have to get one
more hit here going for the chump heavy
I got some gets the reflex punished and
that's gonna close it out of Halloween
man takes it - oh yeah comes another
qualifier that pop 32 apology man look
clean and I gotta say like vanishing
into the corner and getting reflected is
one of the worst feelings I think in the
game because it's just like such a free
punish every time and you're like oh I'm
super dead I'm super extra dead we're
gonna have to see vanilla version 3.0
3.0 gonna have to come out you need the
smaller team he's gonna he's gonna need
to go to the hyper all time chamber yeah
and then no emerge as 3.0 that's the
teen gohan GT Goku player yeah with a
small team so he doesn't get fuzzy and
Kid Buu so he doesn't get fuzzy to death
he doesn't just get smoked by this
character he'll be the one fuzz game
yeah he'll be doing the fuzzing oh we do
get to see that Alucard match up against
PR zone big but Jax Jackson in the
building again mr. Jackson how the cards
not gonna be here playing the recorder
against him though that would be keep us
out of report off leaving I just want
you to know I'll be gone I don't think
we're gonna see it twice in a day here
save him no I hope not my own sanity I
feel like I'm it's like Groundhog Day
I'm like stuck watching the same match
over and over like what if it happened
again I wouldn't know so you this time
though okay and you would think it's
weird right that - recording set like -
recorder sessions have happen on the
stage I would expect if anything al
apart would have that ridiculous Frieza
hat that he has so sometimes we're not
streaming a little like you know just
almost like a beanie kind of thing but
it just wraps around his chin yeah yeah
there is PRS big but Jackson yeah
shadows Alucard making it out here in
Puerto Rico
we got him out from New York he has been
not having the best of luck with trying
to make it out to tournaments you know
yeah he's been sick right so it's kind
of prevented some of the travel I think
he wanted to do which is always
unfortunate but I mean the fact that
he's here is a sign you know probably
better health right so it's cool the
scene he has been plagued Nimba so we
might get to see a Geneva that's cool
I'd be stoked
miss Jackson mr. Jackson big but Jackson
signing it I'm sorry big foot Jackson
but I am for real yep I had a feeling
[Music]
you gotta have her in next light you
gotta ask Rindge about that song if you
haven't already Oh what is okay buttons
are being resigned oh I didn't realize
so there was a set up one talk of my
local that that was like messed with
yeah and Mike Mike Pat was like old yeah
because you can reset you can change
anything you can make like L want to be
up or something you know what I mean
like you can change anything
people ever look at that before they go
in and tell their button checks like
that you know like what's the deal we oh
yeah something shows like people
shouldn't be allowed the best with that
setting if somebody should reset it at
this because I guarantee you whoever's
next will not look at it Mike I don't
actually maybe it applies only to
certain paths or the dual track devices
or maybe it's for profile I don't know
honestly I like Callisto figure it out
later good luck Calista Budda Budda
Budda Budda big this is a half ball
thing to Geneva is interesting too we
haven't seen that that much of this
character I feel like people really
everybody was like yo I can't wait for
Geneva to come out and then like it's a
ghost town a week later right like
nobody stuck for this game yeah people
were really hype on him you know what
I'll never forget is I was doing my
podcast for a while and I had lights on
one time and I would always ask people
what character would you put in the game
if you could have them run and his was
Geneva
really yeah yeah his
he wanted to Nimba that's interesting
yeah it's true I'm just surprised like
how many people were like yo Janelle my
main day one and they've gone like that
never to be seen again
I love to it hurts you when we first saw
him everyone thought like we were gonna
be the big Ginetta but nope he's here
he's pic fighting game players of this
money because as soon as the thing
showed up it's like all the net was
getting fuzzy that's like all that
everybody had to know yeah I thought
people already take the picture that
paint from the jump magazine yeah Rowley
and they're like well he can be fuzzy
yabbies get the [ __ ] down all right some
work being made here from Regina
I'm gonna pick a level up into the
dragon room yeah you put it into the
dragon front not a good not to get me
such crowd with hard to be in here
against the leveled up Gohan yeah a lot
early damage on this
still have to go to see guys man this is
rough buddy last time I like our block
law this time I feel like that is the
appropriate thing to do sparking and
this is going to give out in part a
little bit of an advantage here get set
up with a beat sense that DP through
while the sparking is mana there any way
by doesn't in the battery it's gonna be
a big hit here back dashes flips out for
the level one yeah choice my heart I
think
it's so slow that is one of the issues
with it right is like even if the track
feels like it takes a while to come out
in general
was actually on the drivers first I
believe so also buddy dis he doesn't get
his nearby go Gino there are five bars
on deck big but Jackson I think I think
you said yeah does that thing spend a
level very hair for sure to get the
knockdown yeah already have sparking
anymore elbow drop
I thought maybe was gonna spend the
level one this time for sure and we saw
that in his last game that we saw and he
just goes to the elbow drop he sees a
necessary next kill yeah
all right that one Elsa beam teleport
Wow that job a rush I didn't check that
yeah that was brutal
two meters
it's enough oh man big but Jackson
already just freeze the left for a
lekars the rough spot to be doesn't get
the bounce either on the vanish hold
track super - screw this not gonna
happen to you go PETA sounds a great
confirm off it to you here - over
excellent whoa stop walking there though
yeah that's that's gonna be the killer
easy-peasy no extra meter
[Music]
Alucard is an inch in spot to has the
ability at level three if he has to or
you can go to golden this is this is
Alec hearts best character so if he's
going to make a comeback with somebody
it's probably gonna be Frieza
we're trying to setting at the chase
no reflect you got to see if people are
going to reflect against your strengths
the freezer player for sure I keep
sweating right now so both players keep
making like really close calls to each
other Wow super -
managed to beat it what I was playing
weight off that chocolate
yeah Nuala Carter's gonna let it rip
super nasty beat it
[Music]
yeah we're gonna snap let's bring it go
come on going and deftly a problem we
almost got him there oh my god hit by
that I would have each other elected or
something like jury race right now but
you are raped
Alucard oh yeah even if that legs itself
didn't kill there's like 60% left that
is a hugely damaging slaughter hate one
big but Jackson takes it working all
over the screen
oh boy taking a tick Brook like the fine
man Alucard isn't a bad fight you can
tell that like just the way the man is
spiraling out of control already this is
why I got a lab these characters
unfortunately so you don't think you're
really gonna run into them or you think
they're that good yet you don't know the
match up you are going to get rocked by
it and even if you have lab with the
crowd here you know and just like your
and that's part eunuch at man throat is
really good very good I think how hard
is vanishing out babies expecting that
the canal is going to clown I believe in
this
this snap out
can't no there we go yeah already using
super - ghost-like knockdown
but puts it up the corner you hate to
see it you hate to see it
[Music]
down level three
now the question is is there sparking
beer right I mean DT Goku's left follow
the reflect put even a little late on
the age I like to change the Frieza
[Music]
good check on that throw so sit down
parks getting hit
yeah now we could read to that the throw
is probably gonna come out giving up the
diss we're still coming
I'll back out of there try again no
bread goodness big but Jackson is just
on a roll right now going again with the
level three with dad
gasps barking available of gam prowl car
yes Forks off wash them this time holds
the van in super - chases
geneticist Alec parks running out in
this one once parking already so it's
got him out of that position but he
hasn't really gotten too much out of it
called it the tag in the jinendra I like
this I want to seem something to never
work
Oh we'll get them at the grab - doesn't
get a pounce on it though that should be
in anyway yeah one more bar for the kill
okay this could be the momentum switch
that out part needs to continue to
survive here and not get such the losers
bracket that super - in is gonna be a
good look tell you the knockdown off of
there another setup here anywhere
Jackson also a smart install right which
is you know chilling a good spot to use
dragon rushes have been super successful
b2 bar kill of wine
our al-qaeda I mean a huge light lead
for big-budget action and you have the
sparking stones are not looking so great
here for Alec part doesn't resistance a
great assist does kind of make you have
to suffer but with that jump back jump
back oh this is gonna be the kill
knock that last hit kill no meaner spent
two characters in sparking vs. Frieza
Alucard this is a real real tough ass at
least so gold not gonna be able to yes a
meter to a star but not really a lot of
you to keep it up after a little beer
anything just knocked down paints a DP
surprise for the Miss Perfect set with
the five H though that's the only
downside of that oh good guard cancel
out yeah now you also have to be mindful
of the commandos as well as commando in
a level three is gonna do a lot of
damage
Russell super - 6 amp reflected getting
the extension therefore getting back to
the corner please no scar just at a
really big meter disadvantage right now
thought the plates want to be but that
dragon brush is gonna go to a little bit
of bar form and that's gonna be the end
of the cheetah yeah that's a huge kill
right because now there's no sparking
left we got a really even game you know
Jax another water meter so you have to
be careful any hit in the level 3 is
gonna be a kill even like a roll of pre
reacts
yeah I thought he was gonna get that
punish on that yeah Halleck are it's
gonna happen three closer there at the
end of this air - back in stagger the
guard cancel vanish is it here this
could be the comeback Alec part needs
just got a very careful here against his
Goku's try the 2h and asses over vanish
to the combo you're breaking our hearts
the court brings it all the way back
with solo Frieza the crowd is popping
off right now the funny thing is that
the crowd was all against them at first
right like they're all rooting for big
but Jackson yeah he has a location
totally go and then hands that comeback
was happening now like now hold up this
is like crazy fries that come back it's
hard not to root for him final game
between these two top 32 qualifier here
Puerto Rico
early confirm off the freezer sir I just
wanted to get a Juniper level 3 so we
can fake drop me I love that I love all
the meats that came from it there's
there and everywhere like not even just
in fighting here slide knock down no
break that has been a big issue for our
part at this that for sure I feel like
you know you were talking about the last
game just so invented drag brushes
coming from big Bo Jackson yeah I mean I
was out there running there
I mean if it's working it's working
right here - over alochol with a block
oh this is gonna hurt his Frieza I don't
know it's gonna be quite enough to kill
but that damage is gonna be a big chop
here
okay countess barks lost like 80 percent
still oh that happens reflect yeah this
huge give me at that freezer sparking
running out now slip one the level three
gotta love these animations gon love
these animations blast it and this is
that character that put in so much work
for a la carte landscape made that
comeback now out of here it's Ginetta
duty gokula it have to be very careful
here luckily Sparky is gone on both
sides
[Music]
Albert gets hit like that though it gets
hit this time the auto combo for the
extension to
[Music]
Louisville one 1/4 to get the job done
his only up the GT cofee hearing things
did not look very great for Alencar
could be seeing the loser side after
this to end starter Dennis barking no
other characters even when you want to
do like Spirit Bomb here you have to
self self set it up like that spend the
extra meter gamma
okay that's over really really great
because a great tack there from Jacob
Jackson Jackson to go cheeto
Garr cancel me scary and that's lost
that's a big punish but it worked out
okay
yeah reflects looking for those gaps
advantage is out of there thought even
gonna maybe get punished for that but
get that 2h there
down at the corner
I take the level up again dragon rush
gotta be careful to em could be in here
yeah I don't try to get out Wow
he built the bar from it I don't know
we're gonna see it go to a section here
no mistake though Oh does it beat but
Jackson over Alec are from NY defending
the turkey crowd is going nuts already
it's pop 32 qualifier and they're
clapping it up from the crowd that was a
good one
that was a good match even even with
like the solo fries that come back in
the second game that match was good
already and the funny thing is that I
had heard a lot from the Puerto Rico
players they were saying like oh yeah
this player is good that player is good
and I was asking and big boy Jackson
they're like yeah he's pretty good like
but we have some players that are
probably better but he's like a good
player right and I was like really he's
not even like the best player out of PR
and he's like showing up already in the
top 32 has some strong players out here
yeah you can't say that his gameplay is
cheeks I can't say that it's cheeks I
was definitely one of the few things I
won't say about it he's very very solid
in top 30 to winter side to the crown is
like running up to picture there's
there's nothing but love here today yeah
I mean he did an awesome job and top 30
to winter side of this bracket we have
more matches coming up it should be a
good one we're gonna run down all the
way today
I think top thirty twos at the very ends
of today and then tomorrow we're gonna
have top 16 in the top eight at the end
of the day so a lot of Dragon Ball
action coming up hopefully you guys have
enjoyed it we're gonna take a quick
break and come back with more Dragonball
Fighters pools here at first attack in
Puerto Rico stick around